life on the road it shows tacos angry
course for forgiving guns and these
fights get the flight running with the
runs don't blacklist bounced checks
great a bachelorette comes in the front
making out for yourself and headlights
doing Gollum or missing merge turn
tribal rental car has another mega
church turned Rooskies vagina fisted
cell phone is gone one big law and order
Oh is she talking about that her middle
names how much [ __ ] isn't it yes
she's actually super and she she changed
her first name from how much [ __ ] to
Maria she all right thanks for turning
out of Road stories everybody I'm glad I
got that hummus [ __ ] in there uh you
guys have no idea we're talking about um
coming to you live from all things
comedy studio first of all can you tell
it's morning cuz I sound like Barry
White this is Miss [ __ ] lated um yeah
it's early in the morning I got a little
bit of a cold I was up late last night
but um whenever lana turner says jump i
jump that's that's how it goes whenever
whenever cat reinhardt says can you jump
on in and do then i jump is that right
yeah cuz if i knew you were sick I
wouldn't let you rub on me hello or hug
me i should say hug don't thank open
rubbin off early breathe on me you just
up late so yeah I play a little bit of a
cold my kid had the cold and here's how
it goes my kid gets a cold and then my
wife gets the cold and then I get it for
three weeks yeah well he came it came
from your child than I have been exposed
yeah yeah yeahs petri dish we have two
three two two and they're older so your
your immune system is up if I you'd hope
ya can I worry about you yeah cat you're
gonna die like you got no immune system
to deal with what these children are
carrying yeah tell Maria she's gonna
have to double rent next month she'll be
thrilled to love it I just want to give
a quick out I shout out to our engineer
Aaron uh brung heart run guard you think
after five years I'd get that right oh I
feel so bad now cuz I've never given you
a shout out on our pot I'm sorry yeah I
just think I feel like now I'm addicted
everybody shout out to you because I've
never know okay all right shitty should
I notice a cool however and ice feel
better cuz I bet everyone does yeah
sorry Aaron I'm only give him a shout
out because he sent me a Christmas card
oh well I didn't get a Christmas card
from you Eric well maybe give him a few
more shout outs and you'll get a
Christmas card if you sent a card I got
out maybe a hummus
is him and his lovely lady are you guys
getting married yeah oh that's right
you're like me you have like I've you
asked her yet oh my god how are you
gonna propose right out right now is the
show use the show yeah come on Ella told
you this a write-up in Rolling Stone
come on do you have a plan you're just
shrugs know are you just gonna be like
what we want to do this when did you get
the how long has it been since you got
the ring yeah it arrived Wednesday oh
you already may are ya let's say I also
got his bride so how did you know what
to order her if you ordered it online I
have taste you guys probably pictures
does she have any idea oh so you picked
it out without consulting her oh no no
no no I I know you want to consult I
know what she what Bailey she wants you
know consult the girl on a ring okay
good I zii oh you do this is the ring
suck it like it or you don't I what
you're wearing I thought that couples
now go ring shopping together and then
she picks it out well I just love that
you probably ordered it while sitting on
the toilet from your house you might
want tender see how they met because you
leave your home to pick out the ring be
like this when my wife and I got married
I got very lucky my grandmother died oh
just ripped it off her yeah no I got I
got her her wedding ring which was
handed down from her mother oh that was
really stash awesome I hard part was
digging her up no so you know my wife's
into Holtz she's a costume designer so
she's an old ancient stuff and all that
stuff so it worked out really well for
me that's why I don't want to make a
mean old man choked Sally are you
calling me a mean old man no I was to
say it's a Mean Joe if I was like oh was
into old things Omer you're not old I'll
fight you right now okay we've the mic
go and I want everybody here who wins
I'm going down yeah
tagging on even young spry women kicking
my ass got a couple bills mom I just did
some dead lifting I can [ __ ] you up
mm-hmm what's been going on since last
time we talked Lana my god it's been so
long how long has it been um over a year
probably well I've seen you but we
haven't done this I've been training to
book Marie on your podcast the longest
of anyone since I've been doing here so
busy easily a year easily a year easily
you at least a year SF we should pull
off the email chain I i guess i guess
for some reason when it it's funny like
your show is the one that I book and
then something comes up that i have to
cancel and then there's various shows in
town that I get booked on that if I get
booked on it I'm guaranteed the improv
is gonna call me and book me and oh so
this is a good luck thing yeah it's a
good luck thing either that or me or not
for you guys tired of dodging us I can't
come up with any other excuses maybe if
I show up and pretend I'm sick they'll
send me home that at all that's all it
is yeah so what's been going on god I
don't know besides deadlifting
deadlifting and whoa what do you do a
girl's guitar review type of show yeah
sometimes are you a tonic a triple fret
no I can't remember it yes we call it
that's an awesome title yeah that's a
guitar term Erin that's a guitar term
it's myself and two women named Alison
Alison Gill and Alison Weber who also
play music I met Alison Weber when i was
working Vegas last week or two weeks ago
flips wife flips wife yeah she uh she
came in to do a guest spot I had to
bring her up and I forgot her name
mm-hmm I felt really bad because I all
my listeners know how much of a stickler
I am for getting names right because
everybody screws up my name and then I
just I'd never met her before I know
flip forever and I just I'm like I just
boy it was a two-man show so I was doing
a half hour and then the guy behind me
is doing 40 and like you just come up
bring you know you do five then bring
her up and do five and then do 15 or
whatever so it was like almost like
emceeing or whatever and I just based on
her name man based on her name and I
felt really bad but shame care she
doesn't care just so sweet and then five
minutes in she came out and
the raunchiest yeah the rachis dirtiest
songs yeah notion and songs about
cocaine and um they got mixed response
aying it's not funny it was just for
that kind of like yes I guys why litter
is like hey welcome to the show [ __ ]
songs alright first they're like what
Scott but then they came around yeah
yeah she's and their their covers so
she's like oh yeah that's right yeah she
did a summer 16 yeah they're parodies
okay so there any so she doesn't get
sued say parodies yes parodies and she's
a sweet lady so when she does this
filthy filthy stuff yeah she's got these
big blue eyes and I think they're blue
and then and she's like and then like
[ __ ] comes our because I'm you're like
whoa she's so sweet and so yeah she's
very sweet nap I would be very throne by
that's the whole shtick yeah but yeah so
we do um we do a show with three women
that play funny songs I don't feel like
I'm quite that dari know when I first
started that I had a few so we're gonna
have a dirt although yeah right you
don't feel you're that dirty not as much
what's anymore first album um my first
one I think was dick jokes another sort
of love songs yes I'm your second know
if these lips could talk mmm not you're
not talking about your mouth are you no
no no I special so I wrote a song about
it so yeah oh so I wrote a song about
dirty anymore I just don't go right for
the jugular as I like at one time maybe
you gonna grow out of they kind of get
bored of that yeah not as much fun huh I
think well I think you grow out of your
material anyway no matter if it's ready
or sure you mature like I'm so sick of
doing dad material but is you just sick
of being a dad dad that comes down to
will you guys take me somewhere I just
heard wine where one kid I have one
child yes one child haven't second child
no and then you'll have new material do
you have any children no that's where
she um 33i ask you all do ya oh really i
was always die you look much younger
Alice both are you look very young for
your age I know your ancient Lana ah
it's a already made no mistake
say I just have a he's have a bit about
that I say that I look good for my age
because I haven't had any children I
think that if you have kids young them
there it's just stressful yeah it's it I
it's as not to say on cliche or a
topical or the view like but Dad body
exists like I've noticed my body is
completely changed since I've had a kid
that's all I'm gonna start CrossFit next
week but I'm looking at other dads and
who are comics and I won't say their
names who used to be really fat and
skinny and then I saw one on late night
the other night I'm like wow he's put on
some weight cuz he has two kids had a
couple other friends yeah so dad you
know it's bad enough that a baby ruins
my wife's body but now it's gotta ruin
mine come on hmm maybe it's too much
just hanging out with it but you can be
active with your kid you look like
you're out of shape either that's what
tell us going for cash yeah you just
wanna hear that how many times I mean a
compliment here before you guys [ __ ]
[ __ ] favor gee Karen come on hey
that's how many I often do you go
surfing yeah you would really fit i surf
almost every day that's and everyone I
got to come and do radio in the morning
it in am there's a nice swell and decay
that Aaron there's a decent swelling
affected that I mean if you go every
single every day I tried to well now i
can because he's in preschool but before
you you couldn't write off the kid and
then go surfing yeah it's pretty sweet
deal that is a sweet deal it's a pretty
sweet even be living on the west side so
it's 10 minutes from the ocean haha so
nice so but you know for long but then
he I'm sure my listeners I've heard me
[ __ ] about this for the last how old is
he three and a half years but he naps or
used to up until a week ago from like
one till five so in the winter oh I'm
like I'm on the couch from one till the
next morning you know cuz I just hang
out that that guys are gonna watch him
at the house so I smack ouch and then I
turn into Jabba anyway this isn't about
Marie's is about Lana and cat do you
guys tour together we have a little bit
oh come on yeah I see a little continue
what fight we're gonna fight both of you
have obnoxiously perfect teeth
I have nothing to say yeah noxious Lee
perfect yeah yeah yeah I I like my teeth
mm I braces and I I did care of them my
parents call my teeth and investment
really yeah cuz I used to like I'd like
open something my teeth my mom but God
dad Joe yeah what are you doing your
teeth are an investment I'll jab braces
for a year and a half Howard you up or I
had braces on my baby teeth um for a few
years and then I had braces on my like
adult teeth as well was like I think it
was like six years they saw your baby
teeth I say that's a poor investment
your parents part you know they come out
you'd have to be my mother she's I'm
sure my what's it called um I almost
called him a dermatologist what it was
it honest I'm sure my orthodontist had
some some dog and pony show about how
you need to get your your baby teeth
straightened so the adult teeth growing
easier or something hello what would I
sold thousands of dollar I'm sure yeah
I'm sure nice to know cat came from a
family has money to burn hilarious so
have you guys the teeth how come you
guys don't tour together more do you not
really like each other no well be I got
like an awesome so I met lon a couple
years ago and started doing their
podcast and then Lana um got me this
amazing gig well first you just come out
like I'd bring you with me on some local
stuff yeah that's true that's true I had
done some local shows with her before
and then I came out on the road with
them with Lana and Ralphie this year to
shoot a documentary oh yeah oh you told
me about time and and then yeah so
basically it was like just an amazing
experience I got to travel let me think
I'm gonna tell him how that happened
though because I was super cool lately
so um we shot a little what I meant on
the type of parody sketch yeah um it's
really fun because we've done a couple
sketches this year do and she emailed it
to me cuz she edits and helped produce
and just all around like an amazingly
gifted person and i'm watching
investment i hear you should start
investing so I I watched this you know
this first edit that she gave and his
immediately started writing notes and in
the video that popped up right after
that one was a documentary that she had
done in call
and it was about eating you know like
eating out of the truck I don't like do
with this justice is it's she ate out of
the trash in New York for a month and
did a it's a whole process or yes oh
yeah no I really did it yet there's a
whole movement on that one called
freeganism yeah what's it called
freeganism freeganism freakin freakin to
freegans it's really and where can
people find the documents driving yeah
but the movement might thinking of
something else maybe it is freeganism
okay I was I felt like dumpster diving
was like a derogatory term toward it no
I mean no they said when people are
super proud of dumpster diving okay but
some people dumpster dive and not for
food freegans are like specifically for
food okay and um but then there's also
people who will will go get food out of
the trash who aren't freegans because
Regan's only eat their vegan unless the
food is free and like I wasn't an
opportunist to me but there's other
people who aren't vegan unless if it
they just they just find food out of the
trash but um it's a very stern yeah
they're homeless but uh um yeah so where
can people find it like if it oh it's on
my website um if you go to cat reinhardt
com well it cuz that's impossible CIT
our age 7 hard part with a cat da ya
booties I know yes CIT rhi neh a rt.com
and then I guess I've you just Google
cat Reinhardt it's called trash nation
it's so good like though in my youtube
channel it was one of those things where
it popped up and i was like oh ma it's
late at night i'm tired i got to be up
super early and I this thing pops up and
I can't stop watching and I'm just like
why she wowed me cuz I known her for why
don't she never mentioned this thing to
me and then so the next day I picked up
the phone and I caught on his like what
are you what do you want to do with your
life this pretty cool is it was it was
fun to have like a talented person in a
position there to help ask my mom and
dad she's okay re thats is so rude yes
is that what's rude what do you want to
do with your noise
your life after you get your braces off
mom agreed she was like I saw your
document what do you want to do and I
was like I know like I want to make
movies and and do comedy and she was
like here you go nice yeah I mean so
like what transpired in the few months
after that was I had this idea that if
we just got a camera and we started
shooting it well because okay so my
husband Ralphie May is a very big man
and we've been together for 17 years and
um I love him to death and I want him to
be healthier because we've had a rough
for years of his health right right you
know a lot of things and he's in he's
actually for a man his size in good how
if he doesn't have any heart problems he
doesn't have any diabetes doesn't have
any of the stuff that you would expect
him to help how's this cholesterol good
it's good that's the only question I
don't ask I don't write it's good but
his joints hurt no sure and all that's
known so like so when he was he did a
show called celebrity fit club in which
he lost 72 pounds of fat but they can't
they hurt remember him on it i watch
that they injured him the one that
really then they make they make these
like morbidly obese people run up a
mountain and yeah and so but anyways he
did so good he was so did I mean he is
one of the most disciplined people I've
ever seen I just I believe in his
abilities so much and um and so I
thought maybe one of the things is we
need to record it and that way there's
also this sort of like diarrhea and a
love letter to the fans and people can
you know I don't know I don't know
really in hindsight I don't it all seems
really crazy now but um but we started
filming we had a year and it's not over
I don't owe you still filming well we're
not filming currently but we're not
doing anything right now and right now
it's a little dodgy mi galería yeah yeah
I would have came camera we have a lot
we have a lot of content that's really
good from out on the road in just their
lives and I think it's a really
interesting story that's kind of turned
into something else um then what it
intended to be but that's all that's my
favorite kind of documentary it's always
true of documentaries this one
especially it's a really good story I'm
really really excited about it and um
but no it's not done right now we're
kind of waiting to see what's happening
next weekend
and continue doing it we'll see where
I'm hopeful and I know lon is hopeful
and um and uh it's we should all go out
on the road and film it and I'll go with
you because I'm a troublemaker yeah
let's just make it a reality show Joseph
Juran can pass out on top of Ralphie and
I'd like no way I love you oh and I'm a
baby I want a little bit it yeah I met
Ralphie I don't think I met you I think
you see Ralphie came out here first and
you were still in texas right is that
correct you know he was living out here
when I met him so maybe that's it maybe
you guys weren't moving in yet well yeah
I mean he was living out here for
probably a year before I met him but he
had to come back to Texas regularly to
make money and can't make money out here
sure and so he would that's when we met
on one of it like he was back in town
for a few months over the summer I hear
and to walk into the laughs stop went
that oh so you were back in Texas I was
living in Texas and and seven seriously
17 years ago I can't believe that and
then he um he and I he was at my first
open mic I didn't see him perform and he
walked up but to me and that's we just
we became friends and I I didn't want to
date a comic right know the last thing
anyone would love do I get that mistake
four or five times did you yeah that's a
bad move I'm not allowed on the pretty
funny women show on Wednesdays really
ate it too many of them that's hilarious
just died who wants to you know I always
liked the good dis good cat I always
yeah it's the pretty funny women though
I should be proud of that yeah well not
all of them were pretty funny but it's
liberal that better but they are yeah
but I used to do that show em way back
but um that was an inside joke for Los
Angeles cover sorry Australia who's
listening right now oh my god ah but
anyways I didn't want to date a comic
and I'd never thought he and I would
date because he was just he's so big
because twice he was even choices size
back then he's actually lost a lot of
weight um so I just then I I've it's
like that wasn't an option but six
months after meeting him we were dating
cuz he's a sweetheart because love sees
nothing but love you know
down Aaron you like up season put it on
your Christmas card now use that in the
proposal when you proposed to her unisys
if she might be offended by that I'd be
like what do you sing you saying I'm not
pretty right yeah I took no I'll do it
will do a Cyrano de Bergerac de Bergerac
yeah i have to say i actually prefer
Alfie's very hand Roxanne will do it
Roxanne thing I want a profit I because
Robinson around at least shirt oh yeah
are you all there you go anyways so our
department what Roxanne was in the fire
it was there in the fire department ya
know what do you say a silly song called
the rocks and 0 for 4 different
references I'm so lost um when I'm out
and I probably told the story before on
the show because I ran out of stories
for years ago people are like [ __ ]
take a month off and go get some stories
William er uh I met Ralphie an apartment
building on Sunset Boulevard and
gardener yeah it was garden was our
place yeah I've been in before you moved
in there i think though cuz you i don't
remember you being around it was Ralphie
jay mohr was hanging out uh-huh Josh
wolf huh myself was their part was there
cooking is their father hina cooking or
else used to make awesome blueberry
pancake in there yeah okay you might
have I don't know if I also know that
there was the mexican restaurant next
door hahaha compadre yes old coke so i
would spend a lot of time over here that
whole scene was so crazy a bunch of
comics that in that building it was so
much fun and yeah we were we'd be crazy
broke and he would still go to the store
and cook of messa food yeah my head like
a mess like on the grill and cook for
everybody was a lot of stuff like that I
want to get him back to doing stuff like
that again I'd be good for him and
didn't we cater together ed did we at El
Cholo yeah yeah that was another kind of
rite of passage of the 90s late 90s
comics el cholo yeah yeah oh my god that
was it all the oldest Mexican restaurant
in the country hires young white comics
to cater for them Joe comics it was it
was but it was you me actors and
comedians Josh wolf Sarah Colonna
Darlene hunt Gavin Boyd who else's
comics were other couple uh
I got a beta maybe I think I got the job
because another comic yeah that's how I
think that's how they did it that's how
I got it was such a great gig though
because you go to these like rich
people's houses you just feed them and
then you take the leftovers and you get
tip 200 bucks oh yeah you hear the
leftovers home and if you bartend it
like I did you just get [ __ ] wasted
on the margaritas all night mr b's
requires are really good and then you
would leave with if they show you a tray
of food in like five pitchers of
margaritas that you just throw in your
freezer right and drinking for the next
year I was such a hottie she go back and
do that sounds great are they hiring now
they always say the good you never know
that there's a good old days until
they're long gone yeah that's true i
went back i mean i would i'd already
started working but I my girlfriend at
the time was catering then so I went
back to cater with her to be with her I
think now we can just go to El Cholo and
eat it's or hire them together at heart
me I'm much happier in that position I
actually had that her wedding we did a
party after for all of our out-of-town
guests and I was like I'm gonna get out
too low to cater this nice cuz I'm [ __ ]
in circles right I've hired El Cholo
decatur some rap parties on shows i work
on yeah and they love it and cuz I tell
I tell Olivia you know you gotta tip
these guys at least a hundred bucks so
everybody's wins yep yeah yeah so let's
cool that's so funny I I know I'll jello
and go there later it's really good they
pay good they apparently they invented
nachos is what they say what sorry cat
song calm down that's right that's cut
back here get back in your seat that's
my that's wonderful we got your spirit
and I hey that's my meal is nachos I
mean it's yeah I that like last meal on
earth nachos really really huh like if
you were if you ever nobody's and you
killed Lana yeah man you're gonna I'm in
prison last meal on earth and they're
like you know whatever you want money's
no whatever i'd be like nacho well i
think money is no option although you
can't have alcohol i'm the owner at your
last meal no really mm-hmm i read up on
this the last meal originated because
the executioner's felt guilty about
killing the person so they would give
them whatever they wanted for the last
meal is kind of a good makeup because
they're not the ones who
some there because that really makes up
for it the next day hey gonna kill you
but I got wings you're some oreos is
there more than one L chilla location
i'm like yeah us right now okay what was
the one the one on flower northest on
toilet well sure Western Western yeah
that's original one was there 11-1
western all right I'm going it's really
good in the margaritas for good indeed
do you guys ever get him fights on the
road you and Ralphie well oh yeah I mean
look you know yeah such a personal we're
trying to get it off right off a [ __ ]
El Cholo go back to the famous um I mean
that's putting in her order online over
there what we've had a rough couple of
months um as of late so I mean it's it's
it's not private and like we even
something appeared on TMZ so it's not
like it's not um I just don't love
talking about it right now it's okay
we're working on it and well I was going
more for the fights on the road you know
years ago in the fun stuff no no we had
so much fun on the road we had a blast
um the last four years they were kind of
yeah cat pull over for nachos over five
miles that's awesome though because we
we went on the road also just the two of
us i took her with me when I lost my
headline schaumburg and I let it's one
of my favorite clubs I love that I
clevon Tony baldinos the bass yes and I
love Stephanie right great nachos right
nachos take it down campus but yeah we
went together as kind of a girl trip we
had a really good time we went all over
Chicago and yeah do you do a two person
what do you mean just a two-person show
mm-hmm no I mean I'll have an opener
future so did you do any shows with her
um I did like a guest spot on that show
yeah yeah you weren't actually but with
you came which was cool but and then
with Ralph did you open for him so yeah
I did some guest spots just like 10
minutes hmm before chad and corey all
right yeah so it was really fun in
theaters it was it was really cool yeah
he gets to work these beautiful theaters
it's hard not to want to work those gigs
but at some point for me I i realized
i've been his feature act probably five
years longer than i need it to and I did
it
cuz you know he's my husband and he
travels and I'm going to keep the family
together I'm gonna go to him bring the
kids want to do our best to be this like
von Trapp like Road family we got this
tour bus we're going to make this work
and it doesn't really work unless
everybody really wants it to work and
it's it's hard man so and then also the
fact that i was i was really pushing
because i'm like i'm done with 25
minutes i need and so he i was doing
like 35 in front of him and that's a lot
of time there's a lot of time what's i
doing an hour he does he does two hours
two hours yeah but I I just couldn't do
25 minutes you know I feel good in my
sin my body and then you know it just
it's I was doing it with my eyes closed
right word and so and i wanted to
headline more and you can't if you stay
in that cush feature spot too long it's
like I know a lot of people never never
grow out of it until that headliner dies
and then they're screwed because I know
a lot of people who were opening for the
big names in the 80s and 90s who have
now passed on and now they're having to
headline and struggle to get those
headlining spots because they're known
as somebody's opener it's even worse to
be known as somebody's wife and feature
because people don't give you a lot of
credit because they think that you don't
well you did get the gig cuz yours you
are sleeping but you don't get a lot of
credit for necessarily actually being
good at what you do until they see you
performer like oh holy [ __ ] you're good
but that first night in the club if they
don't know me when I go in there just
waiting for me to suck and they're like
oh so glad you didn't suck and I'm like
really because you wouldn't have thought
that about the dude that he brought in
and that dude does suck yeah you know ya
know I've my friend I work a lot with
Allison brain Allie Breen and die
brought her to chomp she was just
happened to be in Chicago I said come to
a guest spot in front of me and was
we're sitting in the back I go you know
everybody here thinks we're [ __ ]
that's like yeah I know that said why
everybody's being nice to me look at
those things oh that's funny I mean it's
a really tough industry at any industry
for women don't you know when a guy
brings you long but that's why it's
really nice to be a woman bringing a
woman along cuz everybody thinks I'm
[ __ ] her so yeah
oh yeah hopefully hopefully they think
yeah cat everybody's [ __ ] yeah tell
you got on the podcast it's actually
probably true to some of the female
comedian try more calm and then we think
but um yeah so bringing cat on are
bringing add noise as a comic I'm so
thrilled to bring anybody along you know
you just feel like you can pay something
forward that somebody else it for
yourself yeah that's what I like man I
mean I like bringing guys I have a
couple friends that I like to bring with
me on the road if I can or at least
locally because I can't afford to pay
them you know right what the club's
gonna pay them which is next to nothing
nowadays for a middle act right yes you
do look I've just had a funny sure like
oh I five years too long featuring for
Ralphie and I'm like I'm probably five
years too early to do guest spots for
y'all so it's like start to like do ten
minutes in a theater in front of a
thousand people and then go back on
Ralphie's tour bus knowing that like in
a couple years maybe i'll be on a
Tribble run such a weird like in I don't
know what's gonna it's good training
around though man yeah SH I'm is good
stage time yeah I don't think you're
doing a five minutes set in front of a
thousand people is that much different
if you're just got thrown in the mix and
you know and you been you pulled it
together which means you were ready to
do it you were able to is it who said it
was the thing that was on this show was
like it's easy to kill in front of 5,000
do it in front of 12 yeah I I agree with
that I had a harder time coming back to
LA and like doing the open mics like it
was super fun in the theaters and people
come to me afterwards and like offer me
drugs that's when I knew I was like oh I
must be like when strangers offer you
weed you're doing good job that's what I
told myself it has been offered drugs in
a long time I miss it which I don't know
I just look I guess I just have some I
don't really care I like Dre maybe it's
the beaning be in the hoodie I don't
know why people offer me drugs we're in
a stone temple pilots shirt well to
Britain really too soon
you know this yes yeah which stinks cuz
on my album earlier this year I have a
Scott while and overdosing reference yes
I swear to God what are the chances out
I mean it's kyle is pretty good it's the
reason I pick Scott Ryland okay but I
don't say you dies I say you over dust
again yeah and so yeah so when as this
is recording no Scott while I just
passed away last night so there you go
so you know I'm not gonna go back and
take it off or anything you know no you
it's it's just it's it's fresh yeah
that's all yeah don't change the
reference to uh who now I don't know you
don't know what's a scat she's obviously
into the drug same thing I see you leave
it alone yeah I seen Charlie Sheen
Charlie Sheen yeah I'm not gonna doing
that that's on my album anyway retire I
retired drugs anymore with Charlie
that's true gamer past the drugs and
we're on to HIV with that one of the
other slasher someone that but they all
none of him like none of them do drugs
anymore like they witters yeah like I
used to work at the ritz-carlton at the
pool bar oh yeah and it was a bartender
there for a couple of summers in they
would in the one in Beverly Hills um no
on the marina and marina token and but
like it's like this pool but i'm
probably not i'll talk about this but
[ __ ] them um it was like a pool by the
marina and we'd get like some
celebrities would come by there and just
like hang out by the pool and it would
be let so noisy beauties like old
burnout musicians like the Sex Pistols
would come and stay alive and then like
flee for some reason from Red Hot Chili
Peppers would come in like in all these
like kind of and they would all just
drink like seltzer water and they'd all
been sober for years and it was just
kind of sad and awakes I'm like no you I
mean I guess it's great that you get
sober but look like don't you want to
have it pina colada flee like yeah like
you can't you can't have one drink I
mean I get it I hear just one it's like
you have a problem raising back of the
day it'll be okay then you got to flee I
got to cut you off I don't know where
you can buy smack around here don't let
my hoodie and beanie foolio no but those
I mean those guys it's like it's like
comics man all like calm the generation
before me are all sober because they
drank themselves in silly yeah you know
ruined their lives i guess half of them
got me I don't know yeah I'm still
trying to drink and ruin my life yeah I
don't like to be a little coffee I'm
like I hope that I don't ever have to
just not drink period I hope that like I
can always it never becomes like a
really big problem but the fact you're
saying that now yeah yeah I'm thing I
hate her cat hey wanna put the brakes on
for a little bit no I'm pretty good
about no I mean I just drink socially
but I just I had the idea of never
having a drink again call denial okay
okay socially like the vodka bottles
touch behind the toilet but its social I
mean I put the empties way in the bottom
so Maria doesn't see them I have a
bottle of jamo in my travel bag but
words this is actually in a meeting here
yeah Aaron would you like to read the
minutes please look I know if they read
minutes and I do we do I think not the
minutes but they start out with the
whole I you ever work a groom's yes they
are so uncommon bass and the na oh those
are really fun you can say anything when
you know that there's a percentage of
people who suck dick for drugs you're
like yes I can say whatever I want in
front of you dirty [ __ ] well it's so
much fun that's hilarious yeah yeah love
that they don't give you it don't say
this don't say that at the AAA don't
really like no they don't do they ever
tell you not to say oh yeah so I'm
saying they don't know cuz they've all
done crazier shooting you've ever
thought of as opposed to the military
where they just watch their friend get
blown up right let's say [ __ ] yeah oh
really what did they say when they got
shot pooping really good God they told
you to keep it clean the military those
are the dirtiest no yo this is a good
road story when I first then talk about
going in 34 minutes in I was doing
something early in your career that you
probably should not have I
I got to perform an M in Frankfort for a
bunch of the US military and I did
that's another country cat yeah thank
you caromon do you think you've actually
been there thank you okay you look very
Aryan by the way you could find hurt
yeah right gibble eyes open them up no
in bloodshot not you know strike so fun
anyhow I did it I did a Holocaust
reference and apparently you can't do
that when you're in Germany in front of
me really can't do that a lot of places
would be the place to make a Holocaust
reference you know I just was like this
is the one this is where it's going down
but in front of my US troops they should
have cared yeah take care oh yeah I it
was apparently still touchy subject oh
yeah yeah it didn't happen no yeah I
really don't talk if we don't talk about
it it would never happen that's my
parents approach life we can talk six
million did not die we're always your
holocaust joke now that I open a can of
horrible things it was something stupid
like I took the train to Dachau and I'd
something like 6 million served I don't
know like it was a cramped ride I don't
know something stupid I don't know this
is it was funny it was a funny joke oh I
believe you had a very funny person but
it just you know I got in trouble for it
no of course you're like you can't you
know you're here you're here many
stories about like especially robert
schimmel and where you're like hey don't
say this and then they go up and open
with the exact same thing and kills but
it's like 1 in 10 or 15 usually when you
go up and say something you're not
supposed so you get fired you're never
hired back it doesn't go well so there's
usually like well you know a handful of
handful of jokes that work that way I'll
be did that it on the ryman he had a
show at the Ryman he hosted an event in
February and they gave him this whole
long list backstage of things he
couldn't say and they were like this is
the Ryman like Willie Nelson used to
perform here or like or like all these
legends and be respectful this stage and
you cannot this used to be a church and
this is famous venue you can't like
swear say these things and you just got
up there and
you know typical Ralphie was basically
like [ __ ] this and said everything and
they were they were mad were they mad at
him they were mad at him I they were mad
at him at first um there was even one
woman who got on stage who like I think
was owned the venue and then like this
is raymond accepted it mrs. Ryman she
got there and accepted an award and like
kind of said something sort of snarky in
the mic apologizing for Ralphie but by
the end of the night everyone loved him
and they were like yeah like so it was
he puts them but it took but fit but
there um did they do that did they watch
Ralphie before they hired i right yeah I
don't know that's a good question whole
Nash I mean Nashville's very Bible Belt
e in here yeah i was born in memphis
there's too many churches and too much
hypocrisy um yeah but that I wasn't
there for that but I'd imagine he wasn't
getting paid for it either probably is
probably was volunteering his time so
yeah then you don't wait you guys have a
house in Tennessee we do natural in
Nashville yeah we bought a house a few
years ago there and that's right i
remember that i have a cousin in prison
down there oh really oh yeah come and
stay at our house and visit your cousin
he's out okay yeah I'm trying to
remember what did he do I believe seven
counts of armed robbery Wow I believe
it's girlfriend dark denim [ __ ]
[ __ ] can't trust a one of them Oh is
seven count I think so don't hold me
that I know my cousin I know her his
sister's listening so I think I got that
right and I'm not spreading rumors what
happened oh well seasoned if he's in
prison still he's problems no I think
he's out I think it out cuz he was at my
family reunion oh oh that's great showed
him whoa cat how old don't [ __ ] rage
against my fam is exactly yeah I invite
you on here or what okay bold the show
is good i'm just an icing that's the
drugs talking sorry i got really that's
more a little bit everyone in prison is
somebody's cousin I'm just saying you're
not alone do you guys perform besides
the Ryman down in Nashville yeah I've
never actually been on the Ryman stage
and uh huh so I I was not invited no I I
think actually was invited I just
thursdays that they dates a lot of my
cat now
so that was when the whole plan is to
turn these two against each other I
don't know that was when I think it's
snow there's no week that it snowed in
national really and then like and there
was nothing there was like nothing going
on and it was like Ralphie's birthday
and you came in later with the kids and
I've all went out but like we were just
stuck in the house like so bored and I
think I went like zanies and did a spot
that's where I've worked in the past
there's a cop yeah you've been there no
I don't work zanies no i don't know i
don't know what's the other venue in ash
that's it that's it that's it there used
to be one in Memphis what that's gone
too I like Nashville it's a great that
was a great town I love Chris don't know
there when it snows because I don't know
they can't handle it well like snows
like once every 10 years uh-huh wow
there's you know and there's not you
know like Ralph you would like to live
in Nashville full time but there's
nothing there for me to do full time
it's like there's one club mm-hmm and
then that's it good you guys alternator
hitting the road um could but that would
mean you'd have to come off the road and
he doesn't really want to I don't think
not right now anyways how long is he out
for he's always on the road really yeah
with very few exceptions oh really yeah
they said they basically just on changed
the name of the tour you know he's
always touring he just talked about Road
Dogg why I can ever get him on here and
can never get ahold of them yeah he's
always on the road well maybe next time
he's in town yo well will facilitate it
no sir unless he's got to go surfing or
has a cold or just can't get out of bed
or whatever drop the kid off at school
hey why are they turning on me now Aaron
going on why are you getting my back I
generally don't have this my column all
right that's a good excuse aaron i'm
selling you out to you cuz you're on my
side my hair and you're on Team tell him
tell him tell him I said Maria Christmas
card I am enjoying your hoodie you like
this thing uh-huh I like the zipper on
the shoulder ah thanks you wear dresses
on stage sometimes came out creepy yeah
yeah yeah actually I dress up sometimes
yeah dad you dress up on stage no no you
spit on a nicer beanie right I found
that I get a better response if I don't
like I've worn like a dress on stage and
like looked nice before and I don't get
as good of a response I used to think it
mattered and then I mean I i I'm
insecure getting putting on clothes
anyways I'm always does this match and I
don't know what but as far as when
you're on stage I don't think it matters
any more what what I'm wearing because
the audience is either gonna like you're
there and they're gonna like you because
you know what you're doing you're
bringing jokes I don't think but that's
something you don't really get when you
first start when I first started mm-hmm
I would wear like almost costumes like I
would go get like tiger but none of it
yeah I got booed banana no but I would
just like get these stage outfits that I
thought were like good for on stage it
was just stupid because I had no idea
how to how to present myself right and
now i'm more of the what what do I feel
comfortable in and what do I like I mean
I've worn heels on stage and I don't
feel as comfortable I don't feel it's
commanding because I'm sort of not as as
balanced but it's not because I think
the audience isn't gonna like them I
think the audience if they see like a
pretty girl or woman who's like dress
nicely in a dress and heels they're not
expecting you to be funny I think it for
some reason it I don't know in my
experience and I know other girls who
say the same thing like it they don't
they're not on your side or it may be
starts out awkward cuz like I think the
best comedians are the ones who are like
the most vulnerable and like the biggest
loser in the room and like out of the
gate is disarming and like makes
everyone feel comfortable and if you
come out there like dressed to the nines
I think that it almost like like that's
like your first impression and it like I
don't know in my experience it doesn't
go as well or they they can maybe turns
I want you to talk about but it's hard
to believe that this person like if it
looks like they have their [ __ ] together
doesn't it where I maybe depends on your
material to you do you address I I'm
only asking because I just started
wearing a suit oh nice I think it's
respectful um it went well in Vegas and
we will let irvine too i think i'm going
back and forth on it so what did you use
in your opinion what she's doing I have
stage clothes you know but they're
they're not anything that I wouldn't
wear repair genes yeah yeah really nice
pair of jeans and a nice I know not a
not a suit jacket but like a jacket
jacket you know I think that them are
you dressed like Chris Martin from
Coldplay
right yeah no I think that most of the
audience when they decided they were
going to go out that night they got
dressed and to go out and that if you
don't take the time and energy to get
dress unless that's like you said you're
just that comic um so I've always taken
taken time it i do i've heard people say
this before that sometimes when a female
comedian is on stage the women don't
want their man to like her because they
feel Envy us and them so the man feels
like he can't laugh as much and the
woman's kind of looking over at her man
um and I don't I don't buy that I really
don't that if a woman is attractive and
on stage I think a woman will also be
looking at her going man I like her
shoes and and be interested in her as
another woman because when a beautiful
woman walks in the room I don't
automatically hate her I automatically
am interested in her and then on the
other thing with that is that if there's
a woman who is on stage who would [ __ ]
your man you're gonna know that and
you're not gonna like her so if you're
not that woman on stage then I don't
think you have anything to worry about
like I would never [ __ ] your man so I
think women smell that from a mile from
across the room mmm like that [ __ ]
would take my husband [ __ ] mmm what's
that [ __ ] man I don't know I know
maybe that's what you feel cat you feel
women looking at you like you're a
ginormous [ __ ] I did I would always
assume I'm like I wonder like when I my
love what I'm just like out on the road
with Ralphie and like walking out you
know like to do 10 minutes I was like
everyone probably is like oh this is
like his side [ __ ] or something giving
her ten minutes I don't want you here I
mean I don't know I always I always just
assumed at anytime anything's going well
for me that people assume it's because I
[ __ ] somebody ought to get out looking
like did you maybe that's a thing that
that's that's I mean did you select my
husband hiding from everyone else on the
bus dad okay the driver the bus driver
bageled a bagel dick they call him bagel
dick really I haven't heard that yeah
they call him big ol dick why is that
bagel dick Dave have everything on it Oh
good i'm never good I've taken about
picking up that's hilarious i didn't
know they called him that I wonder why
yeah bail dick and he's not Jewish nope
no I think I think they mean he just has
a girthy smelling salmon and cream
cheese uh-huh Tim Hortons mango thick
maybe maybe just like because he's
obsessive Tim Hortons you know so you
guys hit a lot of Canada to you um no we
just did on Tim Hortons Canada yeah and
a little bit in the states to Otis yeah
okay yeah junkin donuts you're Canadian
yes yes why you hate us looking
everywhere everywhere climb out of the
cracks there's huh hey i'm using yes
really don't belong and they have the
french thing dirty i was born you stand
with France we stand with France on the
show is that right i was born in sarnia
which is a small town in Canada and then
raised in Toronto and then I moved to
Texas when I was late so we're sarnia's
and near Malaysia such ronto no it's
near michigan but what uh some Ontario
oh it's on ter okay yeah yes anywhere
near uh it's right out you're on right
now ran on I don't know where okotoks is
well it's fun to say that especially if
you say it okotoks no it's a horrible
horrible place i live for six weeks why
did you shoot a film there or something
no my wife shooting a film there and I
had to go live up there a minute what it
wasn't nothing to do you residue and I
my list there's like are you [ __ ]
bitching about this again yes I am you
weren't there uh and there's a massive
flood that wiped out everything like the
biggest flood on record and so
everything was closed like the yuk yuk's
is closed the comedy palace is closed
i'll just let me just you know it'll
doll for my MC services sal dit i'll do
whatever just to something to do nothing
everything was closed I would have just
like eatin food and gotten fat I six I
actually did the antithesis cuz when my
wife would come home I joined a gym up
there and I just went to the gym every
day oh it's best I look since I was like
22 only out of sheer boredom and nothing
else to do you know a toke maybe that's
what you need to do to get your dad bod
why don't you take inventory of your own
life I was trying to help I'm trying to
help
Torin on the on a bus the bus is awesome
only time i ever got carsick or motion
sickness was in him was on a tour bus so
the big prevails got you sick yeah yeah
well I was sitting in the back yeah and
we were writing on computers yeah
that'll get you and I was like oh man
I'm gonna throw up yeah I don't know why
that okay about 10 minutes to figure it
out because i have no motion sickness at
all ya know that'll get you if you're
trying to like read or do yeah you kind
of have to sit on a watch TV but it's is
so comfortable it's so nice so yeah it's
it's lovely i haven't done it in a
really long time that I mean I haven't
i've been on the bus in a while but did
you get the master bedroom they were in
it with Ralph yeah yeah you get one of
the cuts um I get the master bed when
you six klusoz exclusive when you said
master and then I thought I thought you
to say yes you can masturbate on the bus
but master bedroom too I told you this
I'm a very clean comedian you look so
upset I don't appreciate that kind of
talk here that's the true measure of
successes masturbation where and when
and how much you can do and like the
freedom to do so that in flying private
I don't know carbonation whacking off on
a private plane yeah whenever if you can
if you can tell somebody to leave the
room because it's time for you to
masturbate you are the ultimate in
success like you right to the level like
excuse me everybody clear out I must
handle my business this business is done
that's my theory and flying private and
frightened because prisoners are by that
can masturbate time they want like your
your cousin I got me yeah but they don't
I can't tell anybody leave the room yeah
there you go not successful turn your
head it's coming out whether you're like
it or not sorry or watch how many
cigarettes do you want to pay do you get
the cot on the bus um okay there's three
cots on the bus in the middle area and
when we would do like long overnight
halls on the bus um I would sleep in the
bottom one you know I see me really
paranoid that Chad who was above me was
just gonna we were gonna hit a bump and
then it was just gonna crush me um
chadon was his brother's name Cory Cory
their big dudes right there big dude
yeah why don't you take the top one of
me i don't i don't know that i don't
know
no matter that took the box I do it all
back I didn't like I said big yeah I
shouldn't have said that I've always a
phobic another way and like but um but
also most of the places where we went we
we were just using the bus to get from
point A to point is pretty cush and then
we got a hotel room so uh it's all right
um both and that's a great thing about a
twin okay I'm trying to get rid of the
hotel room because that's like there's a
lot of um you know once you tour you at
the end of the day you have to make
money wait and and um the overheads
really high and getting everybody hotel
rooms and all that is just [ __ ] is
it like out of control for sure yeah is
our tour manager that goes also yeah
yeah band is their merch guy right and
he's nine he's gorgeous everybody turn
your head noting it's worth noting just
gonna masturbate on the outside he's a
decent looking human being leave it at
that it is worth noting that he's
distractingly good looking somewhat okay
all right I get to know him but so I I
actually really liked the hotel room
because we'd be on the bus for 12 hours
and and then I would you know tomorrow
in her room um what's the number two but
I like to get off the bus cuz it was
like me and then we know when you
weren't there and a bunch of dudes and
there's like you know the Ralphie's
bathroom oh you're on the bus with the
kids that's like that bathroom is
everyone's but when L he won't let
anyone uses but I'm sure that he would
I'm sure it's fine but I just in my head
I'm like that's Ralphie's bathroom and
then then there's the front bathroom and
I'm like I'm not gonna use that bathroom
in front of all these dudes so you can't
really the front okay so i call the
front bathroom Mexico because you can't
put anything down there that isn't p
like that's it that's all just go down
that one it's a little of all tour bus
yeah I didn't know that when you can
knock when you all really were not
allowed to use it but I'm not going back
in there right but no I'm yeah I don't
know I just thought was Robbie's
bathroom that we had the front one in
yes I I could I just look like always
couldn't wait to get to my hotel room to
just like have Miami tire all right if
you graphic where she can masturbate oh
yeah masturbate oh my god hotel rooms
like when you have the place to yourself
nice yeah oh my god you say that like
you're surprised like that's not white I
know great my get hotel room I'm like
aha no wife or kid right you don't you
drink drink go to sleep Roran you watch
porn and masturbate I don't like to pay
for the internet that's just some places
the the point is free the porn is for
you early i mean the internet sorry
sorry the point is always free sorry um
lots of free point no the internet is
for you all right yeah night a lot of
places it's not so I don't like free
coffee and free internet so you drink
your coffee you can all amped up on
caffeine well into your room yeah ask
everybody to turn their head invite
people in just so you can ask you to
leave so you can answer baby feel like
you succeed it well let's just turn the
oil yeah this is just going down I don't
know what what happened why did what are
you what kind of influence are you
having on the younger generation of
comedians Lana the head I told you it's
just dirty [ __ ] ah that's good kid my
[ __ ] mana and rafi side [ __ ] oh she's
awesome and we've had so much fun like
this year was really pretty man we see a
year this was amazing that's been a big
part of my life now yeah while and yeah
it's been a really good I know it's
weird i went from talking to you two
talking to this cat person yeah well
it's okay he's been hounding me for a
year and a half she's good right she's a
good houndour yeah i don't know about
anything else yeah we'll see we'll see
we'll find out in about an hour i'll be
doing a lot of show later and then and
then oh are you gonna let me pie you I
don't I forgot a shirt I remember that
only way we'll get a trash bag guilty
maybe were you up really what did I say
that what was my response you said you
said I'll take it in the face if she'll
hook if she'll take it in the face what
does that mean why don't you tell me
something dirty oh I just thought what
you were saying oh you think we're bad
that was also a late at night kind of I
could have been pretend that didn't
happen so funny so I went but I made a
special trip this morning I stopped on
the way down here to get a pie crust and
whipped cream yeah and something all
right you can't eat it's not even real
pie can you wit them it's more effective
the whipped cream all right but yeah you
know the old thing like what happened to
the PI right like the pie in the face
what happened to it it's gone nobody
does it anymore but I'm bringing it back
Murray single-handedly I am I am pieing
everyone who will let me wipe i annoy
not seltzer would it mean salts or
seltzer in the face oh that's an old gag
to the spray that Shh in the face yeah
it was very popular when the pie was in
the face was very I think they went hand
in hand am I right Erin thank you
comfortably I'm not usually hit the pie
and then the seltzer yeah wait what I
don't know I'm not so familiar with the
seltzer yeah really maybe cuz seltzer
was Saltzer kind of a new thing at the
time no sense there's been around since
before pies by that I don't know I'm
just making that up reger like they'd
shake a bottle of seltzer and spray at
somebody's face a little song i shal the
special Arnie ah really the funniest
episode of television it's on the top of
every list was the mary tyler moore show
when the clown gets trampled by an
elephant and they have to go to the
funeral of the clown and the clown's
motto in life was a little song a little
dance a little Seltzer down your pants
and that's what makes mary tyler moore
laughs you gotta see the episode i don't
know that it's it's all right look it up
number one you can google number one
funniest episode television ever
arguably it's for the fact that the
clown died and they made it into a funny
episode well yeah Harry so the clown
gets trampled and everybody makes jokes
and through the whole thing Mary Tyler
Moore's like no no it's not funny he
died he died and they go to the wake and
then they say that laughs raised and
then chief just [ __ ] falls out well
everybody's crying it's great oh that's
also i don't know this altar but the pie
is is where we stopped at pi not to look
at saltzer you can take out to you take
seltzer you bring that back i'm ringing
back pie i'm bringing sexy back they
bring in it most Sexy's here baby how is
that an older reference than a pie in
the face like that when i said that i
was it like that's way too old as we're
talking about pie in the face what
bringing sexy back yeah it's like an
early two thousand reference yeah i know
mine yours is like 1914 was a good year
for pies 1914 thats why IM that's why
I'm dodging the question of what what
are you gonna
let me do it Oh should we should talk
about that on your show huh well no
because we can talk about it here and
then people can go look at it because
will videotape it oh I might add video
tape is a really old referenced get you
have the video tape when you're getting
pie in the face did you make copies of
these forests please tell me how many
VCRs HS that's all used to be one
started out man my buddy's my buddies to
make a killing videotaping people sets
and then we would all hook all our VCRs
together so he can make duplicates that
like when hit record all I can make six
at a time to send those videos out to
Booker's yeah yeah the mail about the
Booker's so expensive and time-consuming
uh-huh and somebody in one very
successful comedian used to put her
having sex on for 30 seconds before her
set and I won't say which is send it to
Booker she said who it is and I won't
say it is no I've I saw it like I said
my buddy was the guy who videotaped me
call me over one day and said and it's
since been released as a sex tape a
quote-unquote sex tape but nobody cared
it like you doing so I don't think
that's a long time you got to be like
oops oopsies oopsie I got our boys out
oh yeah yeah i'm sure it would get her
butt cat damn yeah let's call Corey and
Chad or Evan I'm sorry let's call bagel
dick Dave you're being the bus driver
well you guys are a delight you're a
delight oh thank you very much oh thank
you for skipping surfing yeah yeah and
you look like it's well and you look
great you look great you're in great
shape well let me take off my shirt wow
you look amazing okay i don't i don't
see the dad bod at all i'll put my shirt
back on they call me falafel dick I uh
cuz of the hummus Picardo do you start
there we finish there where can we find
you lovely ladies of life well um it's
Lana lah lah lah lah I've been smelling
2lh a la che la jara God if there's a it
has to be la hna doesn't matter if you
take the H out its anal
backwards oh yeah so just remember that
people la hna tu RN ER but if you put
the H somewhere else it could be anal
haha I want to thank my mom for
listening to the show yeah hi mom um and
then so I have all that stuff online
under my name on it really give it again
I've talked don't worry give it again
Lana Turner la hna tu RN ER or check out
the perfect 10 podcast and it's just the
perfect 10 podcast and oftentimes rafi
and i are on it though sometimes he's
not in town and its and then i'm
carrying it which you will be a guest on
it in the next few weeks yes i'll be i
got sun of next week i'm very excited
yay I mean yeah that'll be awesome
what's your nationality um what do you
mean like my linear like my like I'm a
Jew is that what you're hinting it is
that we're trying to figure out the
whole time sitting here in your area
drive away trying to figure out is she
juden know what this is yes which
professional I don't know why I'm
intrigued by this right now uh Dutch and
German uh-huh okay cool that's awesome
you're Jewish yes what's Ralphie uh
southern oh so you're not Jewish when
you go visit his family huh no I am I
just they wonder where my horns are yeah
totally yeah yeah Sam that's a little
different I'm sure when he comes to my
family he's a-goin the shirt see these
are clearly Jewish tips oh yes they have
horns and says they're very star of
David's instead of nipples that's right
I dated a Jewish girl for briefly and I
did a mini Jewish women but this one in
particular brought me to her parents
house and just said I told him you're
Jewish and then open the door no yeah
cuz Marie everybody thinks I'm Jewish
anyway I'm not that is a Jewish name
it's actually uh Gaelic is it not mean
sailor but then the Jews adopted it good
thing you put the ick on the end it's
actually gay yeah his last name is
Italian valeriano thanks for doing your
research uh-huh yeah it sounds a bit
Italian Italian Jew so did how did it go
pretending did you hold the depot I just
avoided all the questions and I broke it
off with her that night what's up we
can't do that I'm like I don't I don't
care that you're and I'm not telling my
parents your southern baptists why are
you
I'm not telling my parents about you
anyway what she just sort of like
expecting you to be cool with that yeah
how may I told him you're Jewish welcome
was literally as we open in the door it
was like the opens like the last scene
all right i want to thank you people for
being on the show which we find you cat
I'm sorry um Kat Reinhart Eitri tiny HRT
that's my Twitter hell girl and my
website talk awesome i'm at Marie V on
Twitter Mary Blair calm uh what's coming
back to Vegas i can't believe i just
left Vegas last week and i'm going back
i'll be back there in january i'll be at
the irvine improv in december with uh i
forget and manson are you yeah yeah
Jake's your hands they're here we go
this is this is why Aaron gotta shut up
erin was my intern for very long time oh
really yes road stories listeners I I
consoled Marie while he was in okotoks
be oh that's right of you and uh think
you and Pat Francis got the brunt of it
that's awesome um but he's moved up and
now he's an engineer for all things
comedy which is great he's getting
married and he's get maybe she hasn't
said yes yet that's like yeah jinx it
guys yeah sorry you might be getting
married well I bought this for you guys
anyway but when are you gonna do it is
for the holidays you're gonna propose so
you don't have to do a Christmas present
you just do the ring and you get what
about that's not posing for Christmas as
like that way you get out of buying
another gift no no it will it will get
me out of a gift but we're going out of
the country so oh you're going to
Thailand yes she knows to have sex with
little boys no yours what you doing
thailand right you're gonna that's what
i did when i was there you're gonna
propose to her before Tyler yeah okay
cuz she probably thinks you're gonna
propose to her in Thailand exactly smart
smart move no I could unless if she says
no the [ __ ] up your trip to Thailand oh
good point if she's if you have
available and I think it's great by the
way that you bothering like like just on
your own like you came up with yourself
cuz I think a lot of guys are afraid to
do that now I refused I was like I don't
want your help yeah man it's something
that's great it's something that is from
you which is showing you out that you
love her keep [ __ ] those out of it if
you pick it out
know yourself if we owe and when it
doesn't work out so just give it back to
you and you have to like it you're right
i got a lot of women though I thought
they kidding now you go with the Gary
married where am I know there's no they
be quiet but but I thought if I have all
my girlfriends who got married they like
picked out there ring and I always hated
that was like I know I don't want to
really know no I anchors why do you
think you haven't been married this
later guys thanks for listening half
life on the road it's taco dangling or
strippers waving guns and these fights
get the flights running with the runs
don't Black List bounced checks great a
bachelorette folks in the front making
out for your side and middle likes doing
ball more missing merge turn tried the
rental car has another mega church and
juice keys vagina fisted cell phone is
gone one big law and order